two fires broke out on the east side of
the valley today
both affected several homes and as of
now both units are a total loss
madison cambro joins us live near karen
and eastern at one of the scenes of
those fires
and madison what is the latest on this
sasha there has been a significant
number of fires across the valley lately
and just today there were two
in the same area take a look
[Music]
he started smelling smoke and he thought
it was like burnt rubber or something
and then he runs outside and
he sees the smoke coming from the house
busy day for clark county fire and las
vegas fire and rescue
as two residential fires took place just
minutes away from each other the first
happened here on balboa avenue
and involved a power pole and a home two
animals a dog and a bird were rescued
and it took over 50 personnel to assess
the damage and put out the flames
at first we just saw a little flame like
sparking up and then it just kind of
went up and fired the whole hou
the whole roof was on fire there was one
reported injury but the person was not
transported to the hospital
the cause of the fire is still under
investigation the second fire occurred
just a couple minutes later off of st
louis and eastern two homes were
impacted and two people were treated on
scene for smoke inhalation
neighbors immediately reacting to what
they saw one of the houses was on fire
and i guess that one triggered the
second one to be on fire
the the second house the top story was
implanted but the bottom don't seem like
it's their flame
as of now las vegas fire and rescue have
confirmed that 10 people are without a
place to live
but the red cross is currently assisting
them the cause of this fire is also
unknown
and sasha we spoke to several neighbors
here on balboa avenue who says
the house that caught fire had several
items in the front and backyard area
easily flammable
items and they think that that's no
surprise onto why the house caught fire
like you mentioned or like i mentioned
the red cross is assisting
those 10 people that are displaced
reporting live madison kimbrough
8 news now